American assassin stars Dylan O'Brien
and Michael Keaton and is based off the
character from the Mitch wrap universe
the series of novels very successful and
here we get to see his inception as a
Counter Terrorist agent the film starts
out and he faces a terrible tragedy on
the beach it's a very harrowing scene
and extremely well done and it sets you
up for his character and makes you care
about him pretty quickly and for the
first act that was actually pretty
invested in American assassin because
you get to see this guy go through
probably the lowest of low you can
imagine and then build himself into
something else this extremely powerful
person who on his own with no help from
the government is trying to figure out
how he can infiltrate terrorist groups
to kill everybody because he's so mad at
terrorists and that was kind of fun but
then the movie starts to get more
serious but what saved the movie
constantly for me were the performances
particularly Dylan O'Brien's who's
excellent in this movie and I would love
to see him be given a great screenplay
because in the Maze Runner films and
here he continues to prove himself to be
a very unique and exciting actor who
really throws himself into action
sequences and does a lot of really good
work he's really excellent in this movie
and I wish that he would be given a
better role and Michael Keaton who gets
to really go crazy in specific scenes
there's a scene where his character
deals with his ultimate nemesis played
by Taylor Kitsch and that scene is so
good he is just livewire insane Michael
Keaton like we haven't seen in a really
long time not since you want to get nuts
let's get nuts so it's those
performances that kept the movie
watchable but its story gets so bogged
down in a lot of twists and turns and it
loses sight of itself it also is trying
to be a very serious and sometimes
somber movie when I feel like this story
could have benefited I don't want to say
exactly like a commando type film but
just a little more levity I'm not saying
this movie should be silly it's
definitely a serious-minded film it's
just that sometimes it gets boring
because
it's so bogged down in its self
seriousness that it doesn't really feel
like it has a life a lot of the time and
it's the performances from Keaton and
O'Brien that keep it interesting some of
the actors in this film though did
disappoint me I'm not sure if this is
how you pronounce her name but Sanaa
Lathon from alien vs. predator I found
her very OneNote here Taylor Kitsch does
his best with the material that he's
given his material could have been a lot
stronger though he has a grudge he has a
reason to be a villain he has a reason
to understand and feel that he is the
good guy which will always make him more
interesting and compelling villain when
they feel like they're doing the right
thing
that he sometimes reduced to just a guy
who pops up every once in a while and
shoots somebody and then disappears
again as for the action scenes as I said
Dylan O'Brien really does put himself in
them and he does a lot of it himself and
I was impressed with his work and
although sometimes I can get too shaky
and there's too many cuts it didn't
really bother me but there wasn't that
really memorable action scene that just
blew me away it's all fairly serviceable
this movie I wouldn't say is bad it's
sometimes boring the plot can get a
little cheesy it's politics can be a
little murky
a couple of the performances are a bit
one note but O'Brien and Keaton keep it
fun enough I'm gonna give American
assassin a C+ this could have been
better and I really want to see Dylan
O'Brien in a great movie he has the
chops for it he has the ability I would
love to see him in a great film guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]